er ist derzeit eine der umstrittensten
personen frankreichs komiker und selbst
ernannter systemkritiker neunmal bereits
verurteilt wegen diffamierung
volksverhetzung rassismus
an ihm scheiden sich die geister für
mich ist das kein antisemitismus
eigentlich sagt jutta auf dieser idee
dass alles übel dieser welt durch die
juden verursacht wird ich glaube nicht
dass er rassistisch diesem typ sollte
man redeverbot erteilt denn die
redefreiheit erlaubt es nicht die würde
des menschen anzugreifen
2005 einen umgekehrten hitlergruß der
von 1000 in seiner fans nachgeahmt wird
auch vor der klagemauer und ehemaligen
konzentrationslagern
er mokiert sich über den völkermord an
den juden im zweiten weltkrieg die shoah
indem er ein kinderlied und textet
begleitet von einem als kz-häftling
verkleideten mitstreiter unter tritt mit
holocaust-leugnern auf wie robert vorih
song für den er tosenden applaus fordert
und bekommt wie geht eine gesellschaft
mit jemandem video juni um
wie weit reicht die redefreiheit sondern
verbieten und damit einen märtyrer
erschaffen
die stadt musste sich mit diesen fragen
auseinandersetzen
mitte juni gab so im sechs vorstellungen
hintereinander
die stadt hatte sich gegen ein verbot
entschieden auch um unnötige werbung zu
vermeiden
stattdessen schickt der stadtrat oliver
johr zeugen zu den vorstellungen die
informationen sammelten um wenn nötig
material für eine anklage zu besitzen
liberté d'expression die freie
meinungsäußerung ist natürlich sehr
wichtig aber sie darf kein freibrief für
diskriminierung seien darin liegt das
subtil
wir heißen nicht gut was dieser mission
macht dann hätte vermutlich sehr gern
die freiheit zu diskriminieren
aber genau dort können wir uns auf unser
strafhaft verlassen welches die würde
des menschen schützt
juni gastierte schon öfter in jung die
shows waren nie ausverkauft jetzt schon
mit jeweils 400 tickets das verbot in
frankreich spielt dem unruhestifter in
die tasche dabei geben sich seine fans
erstaunlich naiv für sie ist er das
opfer einer hetzkampagne zu einer nas
das ist einfach ein wortspiel ich sehe
da keine anstiftung zum hass
letztlich ist er nicht verantwortlich
dafür was er sagt es hängt an uns wie
wir das interpretieren
nein für mich ist der könig ein
hitlergruß wir sind den medien behauptet
wird für mich ist er seine geste gegen
das system sowie das auch selbst sagt
und viel weiter interessiert mich das
alles nicht er bringt mich zum lachen
vielen seiner fans scheint nicht klar zu
sein dass ihr idol eine agenda verfolgt
dass er vor allem ein ziel attackiert
wie sein auftritt im iranischen
fernsehen belegt ich glaube die stunde
ist gekommen in der wir uns gegen die
zionisten vereinigen sollten die muslime
müssen den christen die hand reichen
christen sind verloren sie müssen sich
dem modernen islam anschließen philippe
kenel ist jurist und vorsitzender der
schweizer liegt im verband gegen
rassismus und antisemitismus
er ist zwar ebenfalls gegen ein verbot
die unis sieht aber deutlichen
aufklärungsbedarf es gefährlich er weiß
ganz genau wie manipulieren und scharrt
menschen
die gar nicht erahnen worauf er abziehen
er war früher einmal ein komiker aber
heute ist er einfach ein ideologe
er war auch schon abgeordneter für die
antizionistische partei 2009 im
europäischen parlament
er macht nicht einfach ein kommunizieren
er verbreitet seine ideologie auch für
uns medien stellt sich die frage wie wir
mit juni umgehen sollen wir wollen
aufklären
aber die juni setzt die regeln nur zwei
pressevertreter durften in seine show es
herrschte drehverbot wir standen vor
verschlossenen türen
unser kollege vom westschweizer radio
kaufte für 400 franken ein schwarzmarkt
ticket und konnte uns von der show
berichten
er hat sich auf messers schneide bewegt
und war immer kurz vor der grenze hat
aber die rote linie übertreten arbeitet
permanent mit andeutungen das publikum
ist sich dessen bewusst
ob die leute an viel gelacht
juni spielt geschickt mit den grenzen
der meinungsfreiheit vor einem publikum
das gerne zu der pfeife eines
rattenfängers tanzen